in a new interview the former Donald
Trump National Security adviser Michael
Flynn says that kovid was intentionally
released by people like George Soros
Klaus Schwab Bill Gates and others in
order to further their goal of ruling
the world and controlling humanity and
defeating Donald Trump of course we're
going to look at a little bit of this
this is this is from Infowars and here's
what I really want you to think about as
you watch this and listen to this this
man was the National Security advisor of
the United States at one point
and that one one point was not that long
ago it was just a few years ago and this
is what he is now saying now I also want
you to think about is he out of his mind
or is he grifting and doesn't believe
this stuff I actually have an opinion
but I'm going to tell you after we look
at the clip is this for real or is he
grifting that's the question the World
Health Organization which has come into
you know into the news quite a bit
because of all this coveted stuff and
the responses but all of these Global
organizations the United Nations is
another one all these Global
organizations they think they see
themselves and and those that are sort
of even above them they see themselves
as this is how we can rule the world
this is how we can control societies
this is how we can control Humanity so
let's introduce something called covid
introduce and they did it and they did
it for a couple of reasons one of the
big reasons was was to steal an election
I mean if if the Democrats you know
worked as hard on on uh on foreign
policy as they worked on still in the
elections maybe we would be better off
but now of the the counter to that of
course is if Donald Trump had just dealt
with covet well he would have sailed to
re-election like so many other world
leaders did so covet hurt Trump because
he failed but many world leaders
succeeded and sailed to easy
re-elections you know so there's a
tear going on
organizations these are World
organizations and when you start to look
at you know who is who is directing them
and who is leading them uh there are
real people behind that and I you know I
mean
Schwab is one you got a you know George
Soros you have the the Arabella group I
mean these are real things these are
real led by real people who are who have
placed themselves you know Gates is
another one who have placed themselves
above some of the some of these uh World
institutions and they drive them they
really do drive them so this is just
about the craziest most unhinged
hypothesis anyone could come up with
about covid and Soros and Gates and
Klaus Schwab from the world economic
Forum now again without a doubt the
mental illness explanation would surface
here right any more or less normal
person who watches this would consider
um is this a propaganda spreader
or is this a psychotic break and
when you see weaponized trumpism it can
be genuinely difficult to discern
conspiracism from someone experiencing a
psychotic break that's a reality it's
quite a reality and we saw that in the
clips of the people being interviewed at
the Trump rally in the last segment but
but
I think that Flynn is grifting I think
Flynn is definitely grifting here that's
that's my instinct I believe that
Michael Flynn is doing this to drum up I
mean listen
where is he going to get support
he is obviously not going to get it from
the same left you might find some wacky
people on the left supposedly on the
left like I'm not even going to name
people but some of the usual suspects
that have sort of gone off the deep end
on the left maybe they would see someone
like Flynn and be like this guy's
willing to tell the truth but basically
the left is not going to support him The
Establishment right is not going to
support him because even though he was
pardoned this guy was convicted he did
absolutely horrible things so much of
the right's not going to support him
either so the constant the the potential
constituency for someone like Michael
Flynn to make money from and to get
speaking gigs is going to be the Q Anon
type conspiracy theorist so my instinct
is that he's wacky but that he doesn't
believe this stuff and that this is a
grift the crazy part though is that
there are many people who will watch
this
and hear him talk about it and they'll
go yeah yeah yeah George Soros is
responsible for covid that that makes a
lot of sense to me they'll not along to
it and that's an extraordinarily
disturbing thing one of our long time
sponsors is vincero collective I love
vincero's watches you've heard me talk
about them before they now offer
sunglasses and a bunch of other premium
accessories for men and women vincero is
committed to creating exceptionally
crafted watches and accessories and
doing so ethically fair pricing carbon
neutrality vincero puts their principles
first which is important to me I just
picked up the Rogue from vincero in
gunmetal and red I love the intricate
design on the watch face and the
multiple sub-dials the durable black
silicone strap looks great with just
about anything I'm wearing in all of
vincero's products whether it's the
watches the glasses men's or women's you
can just see and feel the quality so if
you want to elevate your look or you
want to find the perfect Valentine's Day
gift for that special someone pick
something up at vincero vincero
Collective is giving my audience 15 off
all products and free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below